vict I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we G no value to ha how run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one yeah okay I hope you're ready for
this episode 350 because Tom today he's
on fire we've never seen this much paper
and notes on Tom's side of the desk
there's a war going on between Vinnie
and Tom right now just asked Tom how
much coffee he's had his answer was
legendary but uh aside from that a lot
is going on we haven't done a podcast
since I want to say what Friday the last
week
but even from Friday till today I feel
like we're already behind the aall right
there's so many things going on Iowa
caucus happened last night guys were
asking us to you know do a late night I
said let's just do it today we got a lot
of stuff to cover today um let me give
you some of the stories we're going to
talk about today then I'll give you an
update a very important election uh
that's taking place that's maybe more
important than Iowa caucus but I'll give
you that update here in a second so one
we'll cover uh the feud with Vic and
Trump because you know what the shots
that was taken at Trump what prompted it
I have some kind of an idea I think on
what caused that uh and then at the same
time vivec drops out suspends the
campaign and politely says he's going to
be endorsing he endorses Trump makes the
phone call to him then says he's going
to go out there and campaign with him
Nikki Haley gave one of the most random
if you didn't know numbers and you
listen to Nikki Haley's message you
would have thought she won Iowa very
weird literally like you would oh my God
so you know it's either delusional
arrogant confident or something they
know that we don't know or she's just
trying to make sure the donors keep
bringing the money to continue I don't
know which one it is but we'll figure
that part out the santis is so effective
he gave the shortest speech of ending up
second place comes in gives this message
3 minutes and 40 seconds gone byebye
they found him at Cheesecake Factory
afterwards there's a great Cheesecake
Factory in Iowa by the way the mo when
they open they celebrated but anyways I
don't know where he went I don't
know or just went
home you could tell the santis was
working just looking at his face the
last week you could tell he's doing the
99 counties he went and visited
everybody and uh you know it's
interesting what'll happen with him next
and then aside from that there's a
couple other stories here that we got
Biden says us doesn't support Taiwan
Independence after the vote because
Taiwan defies China electing a new
president Beijing being labeled a
separatist Troublemaker okay so that's
that part uh aside from that Trump
speech he he said a I think this the
first time in months that he actually
said Ronda santis he said Ronda no no he
said Ronda Sanz very respectful it's
about unifying bringing everybody
together Sons were there family was
there uh uh his two sons were there I
got a couple thoughts on that as well
we'll cover that here in a minute
hotties houti Rebels strike a us-owned
ship off the coast of Yemen in the Gulf
of Aiden raising tensions we'll talk
about that world leaders meet to discuss
the hypothetical disease x uh pandemic
in Davos by the way when those guys get
together you just have to be ready that
anything can be said they they have a
new top 10 list of biggest crisis to be
worried
about we'll share that with you in a
minute one of the speakers at Davos had
some thoughts to say about Twitter and x
and and you just have to hear what she
says and how she says this FAA diversity
push includes focus on hiring people
with severe intellectual and psychiatric
disabilities that's a true story by the
way the CEO of United Airlines was
interviewed Scott kby we're going to
show this video to you in a minute rob
you know and and I I just I just want to
see how you're naturally going to react
to this when you see it it almost
doesn't make any sense H selling 20,000
EVS so it can buy more gas guzzlers
think about it hurs isn't that against
ESG and the scores they're getting rid
of their Teslas and we'll explain why
that is Charles Barkley pissed off at
the NFL call him greedy pigs for playing
the Chiefs Dolphins game on peacock and
I got a complete different View and I
love the fact that NFL did it and power
shout out to Roger godell for doing it
but you'll see why because had a record
breaking 23 million people either bought
the app they downloaded the app or were
on peacock already to watch the game 23
million Vinnie that's a lot of head
that's a lot of heads right there uh NFL
and Es in advanced talks you ready for
this one this one's a weird one on
potential agreement that could give
Equity the league Equity stake NFL ESPN
in advance of getting Equity this next
story is going to disappoint Vinnie a
little bit but Vinnie maybe e muffs uh
at Iowa's oldest gay bar fear over
Republicans transgender rhetoric
devastating story but we'll talk about
that yeah fouche's former boss uh
concedes Co lab leak was not a
conspiracy theory H Illinois governor
begs Texas governor to stop sending
migrants uh and then we got a couple
other stories we'll cover as well a
couple other videos but before we get
into all this stuff let me kind of talk
about what's going on with the most
important election that's taking place
and that election is the man election so
we announced is I think it's a day
before Christmas or two days before
Christmas I said guys between Vinnie
Adam and Tom whoever from that day gets
500 manets if they get 500 whoever gets
500 mans $2,000 suit on me okay Tom
wants a Stefano Richie so we're we're
right now having a different kind of
arrangement but we'll figure that part
out but they want a $2,000 suit so
here's what's happened once we said that
internally there was some competition
but not a lot then when we announced it
here it got heated this is where the
election's at right now uh with the man
cockus and here's who's in the leag
monus okay uh Adam is at
133 mans in third place V is at
187 and Tom still has a lead by 45 with
232 and the race is to 500 okay so now
here's what you got to be thinking about
for some of you that are like what is
man I haven't downloaded it yet let me
tell you what's going on with man what
would you pay to get a response from
somebody or dming just think about that
I you know I get tens of thousands of
messages on Instagram or LinkedIn I
don't get back to people because I can't
but we wanted to find a way to have an
incentive for the individual to get back
to you and at the same time for you to
be able to get a question you want to
get answered by people that's why we
launched man years
ago I had a lawyer that charged me uh
for a 7 minute call 30 minutes pissed me
off I said why are you charging me 30
minutes he says minutes roll up I said
no they don't it was a 7 minute call I
said one day I'm going to build an app
to get to pay people by the minute not
roll up and that's exactly what man does
do you have a minute to connect so if if
you're a fan of Adam we know what
happened to Adam last week with the
bosam ysf podcast there's been more
reactions to Adam maybe some death
threats but that's a different story but
there's been more reactions from nicest
messages but at the same time there's
been a lot of people that are supportive
of Adam's argument if your team Adam
okay man with Adam Vinnie had a day
where he did 70 mans last week Tom did
80 mans just on Saturday in a single day
to empty out his man it's just a lot of
stuff that's going on here with man
something Vinnie wanted to say something
I have to say something this is to all
my fellow Americans pbd podcasters all
the manors I need you uh it's the threat
to democracy Tom if you guys could see
Tom can you guys show Tom he's Tom
doesn't like trees he kills trees for
the podcast if you love trees just you
don't have to go for Tom he by the way
nine cars he took a helicopter to get to
a Ferrari to get here today he doesn't
need the suit you're not supposed to Tom
relax I wore a pen I wore my neck pin
you're not wearing a pin please Tom just
don't do this guys the first five people
to man me I'm going to give you a shout
out at the end of the podcast if it's
okay
cre out hey Adam this is not your time
Tom stop it guys I need you text
question just let's push today for the
future of America and by the way by the
way all he's just he's breaking the
rules okay how about this wait one
second
do the next five people to man me I'm
going to show up at your house with 20
women we're going to have the party of a
lifetime can't give address away and
then maybe I'll bring Vinnie or you
don't understand marketing if you want
to be sure that your death threats are
not ignored and end up on LinkedIn for
Adam will ignore them send them by me
true
anyway let's go baby for on a real not
though if you haven't yet downloaded the
app record-breaking week last week
record-breaking month record-breaking
quarter I can't even tell you what's
going on right now with man it's
unbelievable so excited to get uh all
these different people on there but show
your support with whoever you love here
with them download the app I want to win
send them a question yesterday guy sent
me a video question I sent him a video
video question response back from Mar
Lago I was at marago yesterday uh uh
we're uh about to announce what we're
going to be doing an event of ours which
is pretty wild but we had a great time
at the uh marago so download the app ask
your questions please guys I'm waiting I
have a feeling someone's going to win in
the next week or two come on baby let's
go marago yeah I saw the that you were
becoming a realtor I was becoming a
realtor rob you want to show and P why
he's looking was that your first time
there no no I've
been stupid questions ask dumb questions
on my neck Bud first time there you've
been with him there I wasn't there with
I was there
by PD realtor to the star just zoom out
Rob marago worth I'm making an
announce suit can you make it big Rob
and then play it so they can see big it
Big Rob there you go you go buddy be
quiet let him how much is this property
wow between 18 million to a billion and
a half you asking if you ask a judge in
New York 18 million if you ask everybody
in real estate in the area they're going
to say billion and a half look at how
sick that place is anyways okay so let's
get into the stories before we get
started again for uh uh the people that
watched the podcast last week basam ysf
and uh uh if you really want to M with
Adam there's a new show coming out based
on what people said Rob if you want to
show the new movie
uh uh it's called everybody hates Adam
it's not Everybody Loves Raymond it's a
new show I got show here's what I'll say
uh channeling the uh inner Elon Musk to
all the haters and the islamists and the
jihadists go
yourself okay what people don't
understand is that after the interview
the the debate the discussion here's the
problem you guys missed we actually hug
and shook hands at the end did
and didn't yes and didn't want to kill
each other so you can have debate you
can have discourse without telling
somebody they should go to hell and die
so that's my problem and it's usually
the funniest thing people who came from
that side of the world who now live in
the west and have the comfort of living
in LA or London or Sydney you know down
under or in Sweden or Miami from the
comfort of your own beautiful house in
America
start debating American values go back
to Hamas land if that's where you feel
that's how I feel and if you want to
stay here get with the program we live
in America we live in a democracy we
believe in a free exchange of ideas and
if not go yourself by the way you
know what let let me tell you what video
I want to start off with I don't want
you to give it away because you gave
this video out and but I want them to
watch this rob you know which video I'm
talking about go go find that video that
uh Adam sent yesterday because
eventually Common Sense prevails I found
the video if you don't have it I'll
texted to youart yes this is the one
that you sent which I think it's such a
powerful of course uh uh message here
that Common Sense prevails I sent it to
you by the way right afterwards Bassam
came to the house yeah Alper made him
something to eat dolma we got a massuse
to give him a one hour massage and then
right afterwards he went to Miami to do
a show and we had a great time you know
with Bassam but this is the part that
people don't see behind the scenes which
by the way sometimes I feel like we need
to
document that as well show people what
else we're doing behind closed doors CU
we don't maybe it's some of the behind
the scenes stuff that we got to show
sometimes that we don't have but play
this clip watch this here guys here's
John Stewart okay John Stewart is the
man who ran when you think about Daily
Show you only think about one name you
think about John Stewart right yes on
the left is not a fan of trump it's not
a republican but here's a group of
people bashing America and I want you to
see how John Stewart reacts and defends
America go played we believe we've got a
few weeks before it starts and we're
just putting together kind of uh the
teams you have a doubt about France but
I have also a doubt about the US you
know what is required from us is not to
invade other countries like you did I'm
afraid as far as I'm concerned the US
were the biggest destabilizing influence
we know that America was built on
genocide slavery and colonialism America
was built on freedom freedom for who
though Americans you got to stop this
America first
because all the lunatics here they love
saying well then it's Hungary first it's
Germany first it's but not everyone can
be first that's the point of America
First is not everybody can be first it's
us well but that's a bit contradictory
with your plan of uh being the captain
of the team because when you are a
captain of the team you don't say
America First what you say is you stand
with some principles that can unite your
team so the problem with your America
first I'm I'm I'm going to stop you
right there America First is America
alone what World War I pause it right
there so so you see that what do you
think about Vinnie I think well dude at
the end of the day if America isn't
first what's the what's the world going
to look like all we do I mean yes we get
involved with a bunch of crazy stuff but
we are the beacon we are the we are the
the standing force and if God forbid
anything happens to us all those people
with all the weird accents their shit's
going down quick by the way let's change
let's say it's China first what does the
world look like oh my let's say it's
Russia first what does the world look
like let's say it's Iran first what does
the world look like let's say it's India
first what does the world let's say it's
Germany first what does the world let's
say it's France first what does the
world look like let's say it's any of
those countries first what does the
world look like yeah exactly yeah let's
say let's say when that you remember
that guy Hitler if he wanted he kept
going and it was Germany first what
would what would we wouldn't be here but
I love the fact let me tell you what I
love this you know what I love this this
the best part about this clip here and
Tom I'm coming to you next you know
what's the best part the best part is
when sometimes stupidity from the other
side forces you to agree with somebody
that you would have never in a million
years can you imagine within 50 seconds
John Stewart went from a liberal to
sounding like an America first guy
campaigning for Trump how weird does
that sound Tom when you see this what do
you think about well I I see I see the
poison of globalism in the faces of
everybody else everybody else wants
everybody to be equal but they don't
understand it doesn't work that way it
didn't work that way for Austria Hungary
it didn't work that way for Germany it
didn't work that way for Spain and
Portugal during the the Age of
Exploration that was funded by gold and
the kings and queens it didn't work it
worked when America showed up talking
about freedom and nobody was a Spaniard
nobody was Portuguese nobody was German
we all became Americans under a
constitution and an ability to live here
Freedom there is no race in America
we're everywhere we are everyone from
somewhere that's who we are and I see
the poison of globalism here that wants
to take down the very thing that has
been the beacon of Defense what does
Europe look like if the US doesn't get
together with the UK in World War I yep
what does Europe look like if 30 years
later if United States doesn't get
together with the UK and a half
conspiratorial and half hiding France to
to help it what does the world look like
go take a look at what Japan was doing
in Southeast Asia in World War II go
read it they are our friends they are a
strong Ally they are a capitalist
country they are thriving but go back
and look what their Emperor was doing
1940 and what they were doing to the
Chinese into doing these and go look at
what Comfort what Comfort women were
where they would imprison these Chinese
women and make them you know
prostitution slaves for the military go
take a look and then you put freedom on
there you put respect for the individual
and you put it forward and this is where
everybody wants to come there is not an
immigration line at the door of sorry
Hungary or any of these places there's
not forget it I'm done I'm voting for
Tom guys it's over Tom's got my vote go
ahead Adam yeah well you know during Co
we learned the term the great reset
right I believe what happened during Co
is one of the most impactful things of
Our Lives not so much healthwise
awareness wise but politically um what
we've seen is all the lies and all the
malays and all the the
media the the the fake news if you will
has sort of been uh realized and if you
just look at sort of the canaries and
the coal mines the Bell weathers look at
where Bill Maher is these days look at
where Elon Musk is these days look at
where Joe Rogan is these days these guys
were on the
left same with me these are classic
liberalists Joe Rogan proudly said he
was gonna vote for who Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders Sanders Elon Musk was not
a trump guy okay John Stewart not a
trump guy but what's happening around
the world today is making people with
common sense say yeah I don't know about
that bro I don't yeah I don't yeah I
don't Osama Bin Laden is the good guy
now yeah what yeah what happened this is
what's going on because all these people
who are 40 and over including myself
realized that when we watched the movies
when we when we watched Rocky back in
the 80s and 90s we rooted for Rocky
notti Von Drago from the coet U Soviet
USSR when we watched Indiana Jones we
did we rooted for Indiana Jones The
American not the Nazis okay when we
watch True Lies with Arnold
Schwarzenegger we rooted for Arnold
Schwarzenegger and jam Lee Curtis not
the Islamic terrorists known as Crimson
Jihad and finally it's the equivalent of
not rooting for the Avengers and rooting
for
Thanos so Thanos sorry Thanos is
Armenian Thanos
joh I watch all those movies Thanos so
there's there would correct you right
now we all know what I meant here guys I
am IR but there's the reality that
people with common sense are saying nah
I'm on Team America and here's a little
hot tip for people no offense to pbd and
his people whatever team
current uh Mafia like regime Iran is on
just take the other side because Iran is
backing Hamas the houthis Hezbollah
Islamic Jihad that's the regime that's
going on in Iran these days that's the
reason that mentality that someone as
great as Patrick B David cannot return
to Iran that's the reason that someone
like basev yusf for all he says cannot
return to
Egypt but just to clarification how do
say bosome you've been bosing him people
were like is bosam Yousef that's what I
said no you've been saying B you're like
taking
botht potato
potato whatever with all the the
butchering of certain words that you do
I think you're catching up to me you're
on track to be right there next to me
but the reality is I'm on Team America
we're all on Team America and that's
where you need to be awesome okay let's
go to the next stories here do do we
want to go to Iowa caucus first or do we
want to go to some of these uh uh
peacock stories Rob how about we go to a
couple business stories first let's go
to Peacock Chiefs Dolphins game Drew 23
million viewers becoming the most
streamed NFL game ever okay 23 million
what a business model right there NFL's
going to everybody else is saying so
Amazon Netflix do you want to do it next
apple do you want to do it next look at
the kind of results we're getting so let
me read this to you on what happened
here peacock broadcast the game 23
million viewers the the viewership
record surpasses the previous streaming
record in late November when the Dallas
Cowboys fa the Seattle Seahawks on Prime
video with
15.26% .99 a month saw a significant
increase in subscribers with 30 million
reported subscribers and a 75% increase
over the previous year now watch this
one here Charles par Charles Barkley
calls NFL greedy pics Rob just play the
clip real quick so the audience can see
this for
themselves uh uh you should have it you
just showed it a minute ago okay while
you're doing it l find the former NBA
star Charles Barkley is not happy about
the deal you have it goad and play it
watch this watch this
yo man this thing showing this game on
not on cable that's low class man it's
on peacock right you gotta
B that's not cool that's not cool
they're just being greedy pigs I'm glad
some NFL players taking some shots at
them I know the NFL is the biggest thing
in the world to put this game on peacock
and make people have to buy peacock
that's just low class ass man and I I'm
disgusted I'm not even first of all I
can't watch I'm going be filming
commercials but even if I could I
wouldn't watch it just I'm just gonna
barcot the game nobody cares they sold a
game for $110 million and I know that's
a lot of money but the NFLs they making2
billion dollars a year to screw your
fans like that y it's just not cool man
at all that's what I by the way pause
that I got to tell you Charles been a
fan for a long time love love what you
do you're obviously I've seen the
documentary with Inside the NBA with
what happened when you came through and
you're the star and you w God knows how
many em all welld deserved your
commentary I actually really like your
commentary but let me tell you why I
love this year Charles and I disagree
with you here's why I think cable is
dying and Barkley is still part of cable
of course and he is still working for
TNT and by the way Charles TNT if they
could afford it they would have
considered some of this stuff some of
these other cable companies if they
could afford to pay $110 million they
would love to do it the only thing
keeping cable TV in business is only a
few things one baby boomers two sports
three big Pharma that is it there's
nothing else that's keeping cable TV in
business streaming is the future your
show inside the
NBA is going to eventually be on a
streaming service if it isn't already so
for Roger godell to do something like
this and his board that made a decision
to take the 100 million 110 million auto
check from peacock one salute to Roger
godell for doing that the NFL players
can and moan all they want about
it where do you think the money comes
from getting better contracts and the
guy that's done the best job at getting
those contracts is a guy named Roger
godell he's brought money to the teams
he's increased the valuation of these
teams and it's only 17 games they're
playing per year it's not like they're
playing a you know 82 games here in the
NBA they're playing 17 games I believe
eight home games for some it's more but
for most it's eight home games that
they're playing
phenomenal job for peacock for spending
that 110 million and phenomenal job to
Roger godell for doing that eventually
every local sporting event when you and
I watch WGN and we would watch the
Chicago Bulls or we would watch the
white socks or you would watch TNT or
TBS and you would watch what the Braves
or the Hawks everybody knew who Kevin
Willis was you know TBS was Braves every
day right everybody knew Kenny Lofton
you knew Fred mcgr you know Andes
galaraga you knew David Justice you knew
Jo you know rocker you knew Milwood you
knew Maddox you knew every one of those
guys cuz we had cable you you watch that
on the on the channel so brilliant move
by Ted Turner back then and they hated
it when he did it guess what brilliant
move for Roger godell and Brilliant move
on peacock for doing this Tom any
thoughts on this I know there's a whole
different story here as well no but
we'll we have one chart for you that
shows the facts back it up so look at
the look at cable subscribers over time
I just I sent it to you it's one of the
links Rob uh no no no one more there we
go there is there there it is Pat what
is happening to cable TV subscribers
over time there there's fewer people
every year cable peaked 104 million
people back in 2010 now it's 35% down
it's like 65 to 70 million people so
what is Roger Goodell doing he has
something to sell and peacock bought it
and then they resell it for resold it as
a profit that's like foot lock ER buys
Nikes from Nike and sells them to you
and me that's what this is there is no
entitlement to Cable programming and
you've got the NFL by the way making
money for its players as Pat said but
you look here Roger Goodell think of
cable TV as a store Pat if you were if
you were Phil Knight and Foot Locker was
no longer able to sell as many Nikes
would you sell them somewhere else of
course you would of course you would
your job it's what you're supposed to do
it's that's your Duty it's Roger
Goodell's responsibility doing his job
Roger's doing his job so look at it that
way America is cable TV is a store the
store doesn't sell as much stuff anymore
so Roger Goodell is finding other ways
to sell him he's selling it online and
in this world that's called streaming
speaking of doing your job I just got
I'm going to take a different angle on
this one okay I'm staying on topic but
you know what I did Saturday night while
I'm a lifelong Dolphins fan you
guys oh is it something else were you on
your bed with Lotion go ahead Tom you
were talking go ahead no no you said
what I what did I do Saturday night and
I'm like maybe I don't want to
know go Tom go ahead Tom guys this is
why you have to manck with me because
Tom doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about so Tom I'm going to say
something now coffee Tom go ahead Adam
make your point Tom don't interrupt let
him make his point go ahead Adam you
know what I did Saturday Night lifelong
Dolphins fan and this is you know you
guys just moved to South Florida
recently you're coming into terms of all
right the Dolphins are here I get it
hoodie and the Blowfish saying song
years ago you know only one to be with
you only one to be with you but one of
the key lines in in in in their in their
musical repertoire is sometimes the
Dolphins make me cry yep we Dolphins
fans Miami Dolphins fans know no better
than get our hopes up and buy the
subscription to watch the Dolphins lose
so what did I do instead I watch my guy
my brother Vinnie osana where Brian
Brian Ken
perform at the Turnberry Country Club
how old how many old Jewish people but
be oh Vinnie you did so good so proud of
you and over they were like but it was
amazing Vinnie crush it Brian Kant what
a stud amazing we had dinner everything
um I did not waste my time on the
pitiful Dolphins who who play with your
emotions so I did not do this I watched
my brother do put in the work thank you
sir but regarding Charles Barkley we've
talked about this many times cable is
dying it's the Boomers it's the people
on news it's people that watch sports
and Charles Barkley as much as as much
as he was not growing up you know his
famous line was I am not a role model I
am not a Charles Barkley he's part of
the establishment now I know he's part
of the well think about it too he
doesn't he he doesn't want to lose his
job like he thinks his job is at at
stake because if everybody goes
streaming why don't want to sit there
and watch Gable but you nailed it
Cable's been dying does he not see the
numbers yeah but by the way the Phoenix
Suns said you know moving forward if you
want want to watch the game you have to
order our OT that's the that's the
direction NBA NFL everything's going and
they're doing the right thing good I
think they're doing the right thing and
these streaming services who can pay the
money and get them off uh you know off
cable because Cable's relying on what
whatever cable money subscription they
get per month and then they rely on
sponsorship right and all these these
streaming services have 50 million
people that are paying them 10 bucks a
month that's a half a billion a month
they're like yeah we'll pay you 110
million 23 million people went and
watched it that's bananas Tom that's
insane for 23 million people to watch a
great audience well done by the
commissioner that got his players paid
smart I I thought it's a fantastic story
and by the way that leads to NFL ESP and
advanced talks or potential agreement
that could give Equity
stake which this one to me is a little
bit concerning and I'll give you my
perspective why I think it is NFL and
ESPN now report in talks to deepen their
relationship two sides in advanced talks
I could see NFL take an equity stake in
ESPN the NFL the league could take an
Equity stake in ESPN owned by Disney
according to the New York Post ESPN
would take over NFL media as part of the
possible agreement according to the
report the post reported that talks have
advanced enough that the Players
Association NFL owners have been
notified of the conversations both would
need to be involved in the equity
agreement as a two-sides share Revenue
the news comes as ESPN targets 2025 for
when it'll go direct the consumer which
will allow individuals to access the
ESPN platform without a cable
subscription I have a problem with this
here's my problem with this here and
I'll get your perspective on this time
is and others but my problem with this
is the following this is kind of like
how China controls the media this is
when you know a a the US government
owning what's the media service that the
US government own is that NPR is that
what NPR is okay I don't listen to NPR
and quite frankly I don't trust NPR okay
because the commentary is always going
to defend who whoever's funding you okay
so you want me to listen to ESPN after
NFL owns it what is the what is ESPN
going to say to him can you imagine they
criticize concussions and then NFL comes
out and said you guys got to fire Larry
you can't talk like that bad things
about NFL I I I just complemented NFL
and Roger gell on one side which is
someone maybe listening to the same path
are you you know what's this bipolar
answer you're given one moment Roger
godo's great another moment is this no I
I I lack accountability there's got to
be a part of it where you're holding
yourself accountable to the reporting uh
aspect of sports specifically yep and
that part of it is challenging
especially to buy ESPN now if it's legal
it's business they're doing the dealing
it is what it is but to me there's a
part of it that makes me feel Comfort
uncomfortable knowing the government is
owning NPR so ESPN overnight becomes NPR
to the NFL and what you're talking about
is essentially a monopoly right because
if you look at uh who the doesn't the
NFL own the NFL Network think about
who's watching football you're watching
it on NFL Network you're watching it on
ESPN it's yeah you know we just saw what
happened with Pat McAfee let me try to
basically loosen this up you think Pat
mcafe didn't want to have Aaron Rogers
on the show and I think he ended up
having him on or not having him on but
when the forces at the top tell you how
you need to operate how many times can
journalists who maybe want to criticize
NFL whether it's CTE whether it's
concussions whether
it's uh monetary compensation whatever
it is I think what you're saying is that
there needs to be an equal opportunity
of voices to criticize but also praise
whatever is going on I think if the
government allows it NFL should do it I
just don't think it's good I don't think
it's it's a if there's no law against it
the right move for the NFL is to own
ESPN are you kidding me good for you cuz
what are you going to do every time the
first thing you start off was NFL all
the programming NFL all the main
documentaries NFL the 3430 the most 3430
is you'll do is NFL stories everything
will favor uh you know the NFL and and
you know so by the way check this out so
think about what are the four Sports in
uh that we have in America so you got
NFL NBA NHL MLB right MLS is kind of
coming up and you got a couple other
sports you have to report on now they're
reporting boxing UFC a few other things
so does NBA have any say on ESPN being
bought or Equity stake by the NFL no NOP
do they maybe I don't know does the NHL
have any say on this does UFC have any
say on this does MLB have any say on
this no so if NFL is the only one that
has Equity stake you're a board member
you have influence more of the content's
going to be naturally NFL of course okay
so Tom what are your thoughts on this
year well there's two paths here and I
should probably break this down because
this is like a two-hour case study but
I'm not going to do that two hours here
thank god um the first path is Disney
Disney is doing things with ESPN right
now that it would not normally do if it
wasn't
sitting here with a check that it has to
write here in 2024 at a Comcast for the
remainder of Hulu that is billions and
millions of dollars that was the option
agreement for Disney to own all of Hulu
they own Comcast they tried to
renegotiate it down Comcast so far as
says no I'm going to go with the
contract that says you owe me this
billions of dollars when are you going
to be wiring that so Disney's got that
also Disney interest rates are up and
they have a big pile of debt that they
that they took out to buy the fox stuff
so Disney is in a problem financially a
big financial problem they need stacks
of money so they're doing things right
now at ESPN that they wouldn't normally
do because it's still an
asset also the second path is cable we
just talked about it so when cable was
100 million ESPN had 100 million
households ESPN and CNN are always in
every single solitary cable pack and
about 11 other channels so if Cable's
down ESPN revenue is down on that well
that doesn't help and then the third one
is the NFL the NFL has watched Major
League Baseball is not the number one
sport in America but they are Lord God
king of Digital Services and
organizations Major League Baseball
Advanced media powered MLS so that they
could have an online service and they
didn't have to build it so there didn't
have to build it that's what's coming to
NFL NFL had a network hey we'll do the
NFL Network and we'll do the Red Zone
Channel remember there's like four
little channels that the NFL had where
on cable and satellite oh back to the
problem that 100 million cables went
down so now the NFL is what do I do the
NFL is looking at it that I believe it's
this is a short path to over-the-top and
online and by the way in the ESPN
contracts which is the last line of the
story here in 2025 ESPN can go more
broadly direct to Consumer because they
put that in their cable contracts
because they saw cable coming down so
next year 2025 they can do more with it
now the NFL is saying listen I need more
I need to sell more I need to get more
dollars for my people and you ESPN you
have the right to go director consumer
next year hey how about I get an equity
stake in you and you help me take a
couple steps toward exactly what MLB has
done for the last 10 years yeah I mean
look again if I'm NFL I'm doing this if
you're already seeing contracts expiring
in 2025 what's special about 2025 a year
after election 2024 right so
2024 and by the way did you see the Iowa
caucus yesterday who came first Trump
who came second s who came thirdy who's
the only person that didn't do any
podcast didn't haly didn't she just
doesn't go talk and by way check this
out vivec who nobody knew as of two
years ago yep who nobody even you know
thought about like who vivec was you
didn't sit there and who is this guy
this guy going to run for president he
went from zero to 2 million followers on
Twitter with billions of online View you
and he was constantly meeting with
others A Star is Born for the Republican
Party by the way just everybody knows
the future sit there and say whatever
you want the left would love a star like
like vivec Ramis Swani by the way on on
the left the star is who say AOC say I I
think AOC is a star for the Socialist I
think it's far but I think Gavin Nome is
a star star for the left but even a
Gavin Nome in my opinion is not the
level of a star as a Vic is for the
right not at all there's two different
people so so Rob let's talk about
something here last week out of nowhere
on Friday president Trump put something
on Truth social if you can put this up
and then we can go through a couple of
the tweets and I'll you know speculate
on why I think that happened but if you
want to put up what the president said
about uh uh about vivec last week on
truth I think that's what it is vivec
started his campaign as a great
supporter the best president Generations
Etc unfortunately now all he does is
disguise his support in the form of a
deceitful campaign tricks very Sly but a
vote for vvec is a vote for the other
side don't get duped by this vote for
Trump don't waste your vote vivec is not
magga the Biden indictment indictment
against his political opponent will
never be allowed in this country they
are already beginning to fall Mega so
now what prompted this I went out and I
saw Vic tweets and I noticed vivec
tweeted by the way this this came 50 45
minutes or 50 minutes after a tweet by
uh uh Dave Smith that vivec retweeted
did you see the Tweet by Dave Smith so
go to Dave Smith's TW our friend Dave
Smith Dave Smith is a stud of a guy so
Dave Smith post something but he's not a
Trumper he's not magga so Dave Smith
post something uh on Twitter I I hope he
doesn't tweet 75 times a day where we
can't find it cuz some guys TW so many
times no no how many tweets do you see
yourday do you see it uh uh oh so you'll
find it keep going keep going keep going
whatever whatever last week was uh
Friday what is Friday can you give the
date keep going go a little bit back go
one more back go one more back go one
more back so Dave swi said something yes
last week uh go one more go one more
let's see if it comes up oh man you got
to find a tweet keep going there's he is
that the one now now you're back so so
anyways he he posts a tweet and in the
Tweet he says something about you know
uh here's what I believe in I believe uh
Nikki Haley is the worst candidate we've
had in many years you know and he's just
going and calling out everybody right
and he thinks you know uh V Vic is the
best one out there to get etc etc but
then he also says and I will never vote
for Trump because Trump's drama or
something like that right so VC retweets
that oh man so when you retweet that if
you can find it Rob Vic retweets that
and to me that's
that's the a retweet 45 minutes before
Trump tweets what he tweeted on Truth
social and I believe that's what started
now I may be wrong I'm purely
speculating on what I'm hearing but to
me let me just read the tweet and vvec
tweets so much you got to go back oh my
God I'm I'm on I'm going like this it's
still 24 hours wow so let me see what so
what is the date again for that give me
the date again 12 is Friday um while I'm
finding this can you guys give some
commentary here while I'm find well
let's let's the breaking news is that
obviously Trump won Iowa yeah and Vic
has officially dropped out of the race
yeah and wisely so okay so everything
listen this was inevitable because VC as
much as we think he's a stud he's been
on the program multiple times we've had
relationship with a guy he's
amazing at some point you're going for
the king and if you shoot for the king
you better not miss and he's been trying
to waffle and align himself with the
Maga movement and America first but the
but Iowa was the first time that someone
had to cast a ballot MH and at Trump
over the weekend was like all right I
see what you've been doing you've been
aligning yourself with my team this
entire time respect thank you for this
but at the end of the day he's running
against Donald Trump he's running
against VC and he basically put the nail
in the coffin for VC so we all know that
most people didn't like Trump Maga
there's some alignment with VC we all
know that but at the end of the day he's
trying to take Donald Trump's job yes at
the end of the day you 100% right it
took one simple tweet whatever the I
found it here you go rob if you want
whatever happened but VCA is now out is
this the uh this is the one yeah so if I
was a republican caucusing in Iowa I
would 100% support be and it's not even
closed the Santa a Warhawk and a coward
Warhawk coward I will never forgive
Trump for his appointments and his Co
policy Nikki Haley is the worst human in
America there's really no debate I
disagree with v on Mexico and China but
he's head his head his his head and
shoulders his head and shoulders the
best Republic Canada plus he does my
show LOL right and so vivec retweets
this the most important sentence here is
what I will never forgive Trump for his
appointments and his Co policy and you
retweeting it is a form of an
endorsement and to Trump who reads
everything to see where you are this
would upset the hell out of somebody
like who's wired like Trump so then M
comes out and he gives love to Trump he
says I'm probably going to be
campaigning I called president I told
him I endorse you and I'll be in New
Hampshire with you so you know what role
he's playing next and the president had
good things to say about him and krie
Lakey they had good things to say about
those to about Carri Lake about dude and
listen say what you want I watched the
entire uh the post win caucus bro you
cannot compare him to Joe Joe Biden and
I'm not I'm saying this With all
sincerity he doesn't like it's sad to
watch I hope everybody realizes that
they got duped into voting for this guy
cuz he was the lesser of two evils he
came up there he was professional he was
cordial he said yo he said nice things
about Ron he said ni nice things about
Haley uh Nikki Haley he he congrat you
know he said can you play this clip
about what he said about vivec and play
vivec's clip as well yep go ahead
Rob I also want to congratulate VI
because he did a hell of a job he came
from uh zero and he's got a big percent
probably 8% almost 8% and that's a an
amazing job they all they very smart
people very capable people you can pause
it and go to the next one Rob and see
vix video if you have it a star is born
with Vic there's no question about
1,000% and guess what though he has to
realize that right now and I'm pretty
sure he's going to take it because you
know he has his own money he has he has
a strong backbone that swamp that left
that establishment they're going to
start as of right now they're going to
be on top of his his ass him played cuz
they don't like him he speaks the truth
go back a little bit candidates in go
back yeah sometime it does that as I've
said since the beginning there are two
America First candidates in this race
and earlier tonight I called Donald
Trump to tell him that I congratulate
him on his victory and now going forward
he will have my full endorsement for the
presidency and I think we're going to do
the right thing for this country people
were unhappy by the way when he did that
FY his wife is also very well spoken
she's a surgeon by the way she's like oh
yeah she's very smart and very well
spoken as well where does she where does
she do you know where she's at is she
anti-a or is she no what do you mean
it's his
wife yeah one thinging is is V's wife is
she Pro Trump does she she does what
tells her to do the leader of the
household go ahead Adam so just a couple
talking points it's official guys the
Trump train has left the station this
was the first first of what we're going
to be seeing over the next few weeks few
months the Republican primaries um
Trump's running away with this thing
next up is New Hampshire Nikki has a
slight chance there but with the V
dropping out and endorsing and stumping
for Trump it's over Ron's got no path to
the presidency it's over his only shot
was in Iowa he's not winning New
Hampshire and he's certainly not winning
what's third South Carolina by the way
Trump didn't win Iowa I think Ted Cruz
won Iowa in 2016 thank I was just going
there thank you pbd this became the
highest ever winning percentage for
Republican primary candidate ever Donald
Trump in 2016 to put in perspective so
what they say in Iowa is that if you win
the Evangelical vote you win Iowa 2third
of Iowa caucus voters are Evangelical so
in uh 20 uh in year 2000 George W bush
won it with 43% of the vote Trump just
crushed that
with 51% of the vote okay in Iowa
Trump's dominating so
uh to look at what's going on in Iowa
right now understand a couple different
things the DNC you talk about Biden the
Republican we all know that Biden is a
weak candidate who is not weak is the
DNC they are shrewd they are slick they
know how to play the game they know Che
201 it is very naive of you to just
think they're
cheaters noop
I'm saying to anyone out there if you
just think they're cheating you're being
naive they have Grassroots campaigns
they're organized they get out the vote
do weird things happen in elections
especially with mail and B ballots
during Co but look at every election
since 2000 it's been a nailbiter it's
the it's as we used with our friend the
other day it's uh ignorant and naive to
just think they're cheaters they're DNC
don't play the fact that Joe Biden is
even remotely in the mix just shows how
strong the DNC is but that's not the
point they're trying to
paint Donald Trump as magga extremist
and the magga base is extremist the DNC
chair Jamie Harrison okay he said that
this is the most far-right extreme magga
party ever I would argue that it's
exactly the opposite they're extremists
with support for Donald Trump if you
look at the exit polling Iowa supporters
about their candidate how extreme are
you about your candidate how
enthusiastic are you about your
candidate 50% Donald Trump extreme Des
santis 23% Nikki only 9% nobody's bought
into Nikki and 82% of trump voters said
they have made up they their mind
they're not going anywhere so they have
extreme loyalty to Trump I don't Mo you
guys Patrick but nothing made me nothing
makes me happier especially last night
because of everything that's happening
is watching uh CNN and MSNBC and all
those loser shills from Rachel mattow to
Joy Reed to Jen the ginger swindler
just losing their minds I'm not you want
to play to Jo please do because by the
way I don't watch I don't watch porn
that is better than any porn I've ever
seen and it's it started and this is
this the one where Joy Reed uh says that
what's it called Nikki Haley lost
because of guess what you'll never going
to guess racism let's see it
and I think to the point that you made
Steph I mean it's the elephant in the
room she's still a brown lady oh Jesus
that's got to try to win in a party that
is deeply anti-immigrant and
which you can say immigrants are
poisoning the blood of our country she's
getting you know birther by Donald Trump
um and I don't care how much the do
likes her which ramp up a lot the better
she does in New Hampshire so it's still
a challenge I don't see how she becomes
the of that party with Donald Trump
still around I can't picture it
happening maybe it could happen Ronda
sanz's only argument for staying in it
is he's the white guy that he can still
pause it right there I have a question
for her if she hates Trump so much why
did she go get Trump's
hair I'm just curious man like can you
you have a million different options on
a different hair to have and you get
Trump look at Trump's picture below yeah
dude you got Trump's hair exactly yeah
like there's no one a bigger closet
supporter of trump than you you're
amazing this is cultural appropriation
at the highest level exact this is what
they're talking
about that jacket looks like a white
Professor I had in college 40 years ago
but no but notice how it has listen to
me they're already starting it's race
it's mag by the way you when when people
say it's a magga extremist you know what
the word Magus the the abbreviation is
make America great again when did that
become such a racist wait you want to
make America great again you Nazi you
piece of by the way all these
people better bow down and kiss Trump's
feet because now now they're relevant
again now for the next four years if he
wins they're going to have something to
talk about because now nobody watches
you nobody cares now all those
green-haired crazy screaming uh the
world's over now they have something to
watch because guess what we're back to a
racist country and we're back to the end
of the world I want to say that yeah
we're back one of the weak words in the
English language in America today is
racist I love it I remember when that
used to actually mean something I
remember when I heard they were racist I
was like oh the racists are here
the kkk's here the neo-nazis are here
they're here the racists are here it's
the most watered down weak word in
America today it means nothing people
shout it it's the it's the boy who cried
wolfed it's the boy who cried racist at
this point and a lot lot of us fell for
it in 2016 Donald Trump he's racist he's
racist nobody's falling it for it
especially while you stole Trump's way
Adam don't Adam I love you to death do
not say nobody's going to fall for it I
am still curious to see because you're
they're they're starting it already all
they're going to do is go back to their
old Playbook be and I'm hoping I'm
hoping and if you're listening out there
and you are you know some people are you
are far left some people are far right
if you're on that left don't buy into
the okay he's not racist this
isn't a racist country yeah there's some
racist people down in Arkansas you going
back listen yeah you're going to find
them but the majority of us we're trying
to get better and and go past all that
stop taking us backwards and
wake the hell up can we can we talk
about if Tom if you did you want to add
something yeah very simply if you want
to know what Trump derangement syndrome
looks like that's what it looks like
that's exactly that is that is what a
deranged argument looks like and that is
where the phrase trump derangement
syndrome came from mad too it's her and
Rachel madow that don't know what to say
so they say things like that yeah yeah
but but you know what let me tell you
though Tom honestly as much as I want to
say of course they still have a very
loyal audience that's going to agree
with anything they say I don't think
they have the kind of credibility that
they once had I think it's hurting them
by the way Nikki Haley here's what Nikki
Haley does in her acceptance speech Rob
do you have a clip of Nikki Haley when
she gives a talk and she says what we
learned here that it's it came down to
two candidates is what it came down I'm
like what what two candidates you were
third place I listened to her speech and
I'm thinking to myself like is the
audience is screaming as if she won rob
you got a clip that I just texted to you
if you can play that one that I sent you
by the way here's some of the things
that she said I just want to tell you
what she said in her speech Vinnie did
you listen to Her speech or no I I
didn't I didn't watch the ending of her
and I heard you talk about it all right
so let me tell you let me tell you what
she said let me tell you what she said
so I was not expecting her to say this
but she said this so some other words
okay she trashed Trump she said Trump
and Biden are both 80 years old they put
our kids in debt they don't have a
vision for our future they don't have a
vision for our future America deserves
better our campaign is the Last Hope of
stopping the Trump Biden Nightmare and
she goes on and on and on go ahead and
play this clip here watch this if you
I'm telling you if you listen to this
without knowing the numbers you would
have thought she won go ahead
New Hampshire in South
Carolina
NBI I can safely say listen to this
tonight IA made this Republican primary
a twers race your third place yeah what
the hell are you talking about this is
what's called a spin job guys in
politics oh my God think about it $70
million later but here's what I'm saying
the donors can't be dis dumb donors who
have money you made your money because
you're smart you busted your ass you
can't be that blind to see this and say
what are we doing giving this person
money yeah you know how bad the score
was the score isn't you lost by a field
goal or a touchdown can I ask you a
question you lost by five touchdowns a
couple things a couple things I reacted
the same way to this so I went to things
that sometimes are inconvenient to look
at the damn numbers and what was
interesting is all the polls leading up
to this had her three points ahead of
DeSantis every poll I looked at
everything that was lined up the only
one and these are all polls that were
through the 13th the 14th the 12th and
the 11th so these are polls happening
pbd up to the minute so instead wait a
minute she wasn't second place in Iowa
that's what all the polls said she would
be she ended up almost three points
behind Des santz but this is what she
was saying she is talking to dandis when
she says that when she says it's now a
two person race you want to know why cuz
this she has 2 x actually 3x the polling
in New Hampshire over to santis can I
ask you a question hang on hang on and
South Carolina we'll get to this in a
minute what she was saying is that
DeSantis is gone that's what she was
trying to say there Iowa made this a
two-horse race in other words Des sis
didn't get close enough that his donors
in campaign can keep going that's what
she's trying to say he's gone and now
it's a two horse race me
and the guy that trounced everybody if
you're if you're a Don did you just
forget Trump's name for a second oh djt
exactly DJ so now check this out let's
go to this I got something to say to you
Nikki Haley and Rob be ready with the uh
the
graphic buckle up Haley is got 4X on Des
santis is that the chart you want him to
show yep Haley's got 4X the sandis in
South Carolina but Trump has almost 3x
Haley and that's her home state let me
tell you a story about home state this
is the 2000 election Gore is from
Tennessee if he wins his home state the
Supreme Court doesn't have to weigh in
on Florida look at this if he had won
his home state he wins a president
you're say Nikki Haley is Al Gore Nikki
Haley is Al Gore she's sitting here with
this Inconvenient Truth you're talking
about two horse race and you're not even
leading your home state so it's better
off to drop out now instead of being
embarrassed when New Hampshire comes
around your own home state I want to
know what her donors and the strategists
in the RNC are saying hey Nick you you
know you you don't even have a bounce
coming and just let me get South
Carolina I'm going to win you don't have
a bounce coming Trump has got you 2.5 to
one in South Carolina what what do you
think okay so I got a question for you I
got a question for you I got a question
I got one for Tom so she was she was I
had one five minutes ago let me let me
let me let me ask and by the way for
those of you guys that are V with man
Vinnie got 15 votes already if you
haven't downloaded man to ask these guys
a question you can QR code Vinnie Tom or
Adam ask him any questions they'll
respond back to you in
text or just look at the leader guys
guys are
just new download the app ask a question
from any of these guys let me go back to
it Tom here's my question for you here's
my question for you Tom so what are the
chances what are the chances cuz the
Nikki Haley donors are money people
these are not poor people these are not
you know small influ influencers these
are Wall Street people right what are
the chances that this happens what are
the chances that these guys call Trump
have a meeting with Trump or send a
Handler to have a meeting with one of
Trump's handlers and say look we will
publicly say that it's most likely
you're going to win if you take Niki
Haley as a VP okay do you think the
money guys from Wall Street the Jamie
diamonds do you think these guys who are
sitting there big you know Bill Amman
just left his party by the way I don't
know if you guys saw that or not he gave
he gave a million to uh one of the
candidates that Andrew yank's been
telling me about Dean Phillips de
Phillips yeah so what are the chances
Wall Street Calls Trump and says we will
100% back you up if you pick Haley as
your
VP I I is is there a chance they doing
that is there a chance they going to
bring the money yeah I I think there's
chance to do that right now is the time
for the back room dealings this is where
everybody comes together and starts hey
who's you going to support what are you
going to do what are you going to do and
you this is where 15 people on stage
become two or three because remember
South Carolina is where Biden was
anointed and they played the games there
so these first three primaries is where
all the back room dealings happen do I
think that back room dealing Could
Happen yeah sure it can but then you've
got him she's not even leading her home
state I got her 2 to one what you what
deal are we talking about
you know can you see Trump coming back
saying I don't need you no no but he's
saying you don't need Nikki Haley but
Trump is all about polls and all about
uh endorsements so what if Trump
understands the power of endorsements
and nobody knows how to use endorsements
better than Trump nobody does period
Trump knows how to just in his talk
yesterday he says look at this man look
at this fine gentleman here I see him
everywhere with his suit in the bricks
matter of fact come on up here come on
up here man yeah come on up here look at
this man maybe the best looking man I've
ever seen in my life I call him the
marro man he's the first man come on
Doug where's Doug
at his event Doug was there shout
out was at his event so but think about
it if imagine Jamie Diamond from Chase
comes out and says you know there's a
70% chance Trump is winning this thing
and we have to just accept it and he
says I actually don't think it's going
to be as bad as people think it is do
you think Trump's going to use that and
say look when JP Morgan you know some
people trust him some people don't with
J JP Diamond Jamie Diamond but even
Jamie Diamond's Endor endorsing me right
now he would use that he doesn't care
about Nikki Haley he cares about who who
her donors are do you think that's a
strategic more or zero chance he's not
going to entertain it last week he said
he knows who's going to IS F VP is going
to be and I don't think anybody is
handicapping it at Nikki hilly I don't
think so people are talking the biggest
things that I see on threads and I I
stay away from the conspiracy the
Facebook threats no I do not I do this
is not an endorsement as Facebook
threats um uh I look at it and I'm
seeing a lot of people at certain levels
out there that are on that are saying
there's been a lot of talk about Tulsi
gabard
and and Lake I'm not sure about either
either one but he's has been saying
really good things about Lake going to
going to be a really wonderful person
you're going be a fine Senator multiple
multiple conversations with people who
are names in politics and if I told you
tulsi's name came up three times that's
a small number okay and these are people
that are in
gav in Syrian means like in
in so Tom you you knew that already
speak no I said that I haven't spoken to
the depth of people Pat was speaking
well Tulsi and and talk deep people but
I'm not I'm looking at campaign
strategist and people along those lines
you know the guy that I talk to that's a
very good you know why I think it's a
very good move you know why I think
Tulsa is great why
mhm so you know the Dei people going to
be like female this this this is that
forget about female okay you know she
would be great if she was a man tulsi's
great period okay I'm not I'm not you
know you're great for a you're a great
basketball player for a female no you're
is great period She is military she has
the independent vote she has access to
the independent
podcasters go on and she would go on
those podcasts and sell Trump and all
that stuff and I think eventually that
could lead into a different kind of a
career for her long term but um I think
I think a lot of people want Tulsa as a
and Cas you want one last Adam just
really I want to know what you guys cuz
I've been trying to ask it for a while
you're a donor you're donating to the
Nikki Haley campaign you know pretty
early there's no chance especially when
it comes to Trump right Tom so what
what's the incentive for somebody to
keep giving I'm just curious that I mean
is it for the future is it why do you
keep dumping all this money when you
know she's not going to win unless you
thought that they were going to get
Trump and get him out with all these
indictments I can answer that really
short yeah the the Horseshoe in the a
party or at play here Y and there are
many people up there that really thought
that these lawsuits and everything and
getting him off the ballot was going to
do it now you've got a supreme court
that he largely picked that's going to
hear arguments on February 8th and make
a decision around February 21st about
Colorado and getting him back on the
ballot and if that happens Maine he's
back on the ballot it's over and there
are many people that think that's going
to happen but at the time they started
Vinnie you're right the logic was you
know the the Horseshoe Adam talks about
the Horseshoe very eloquently about how
the parties kind of Bend back together
Exum me that Elite top of parties on
deep programs and deep funding they kind
of Bend back toward each other and so I
think at the beginning they thought hey
we just got to get through this season
and he's going to be off the ballot
there were high-end Republicans that
felt that way that were behind her and
now they're coming back and I think
Pat's right I think there are strategic
discussions that are being had behind
close doors cuz this is when they always
happen it's not a surprise this is the
season of deals New Hampshire to South
Carolina that is the season of deals Tom
if there was a nail you know what you
did you took a hmer and you hit it right
on the head 100 that's what he just did
so Pat brought up the conversation of
whether Nikki Haley would be V VP I
don't think so I think she's got as much
as a chance of being VP as Chris
Christie has to be the Attorney General
so if you look at Nikki Haley's polling
exit you're saying there's a chance
there's a chance there's no chance so
you know this is according to um Meet
the Press that if among Haley
supporters um if she if Trump were the
nominee who they would vote for Haley
supporters 43% would vote for Biden 23%
would vote for Trump let me say that
again Haley supporters are the uni party
more likely to vote for Biden than for
Trump I think when Trump gets wind of
these polls of who's behind Haley a lot
of it is Big donor ERS I'm out you're
fired but you bring up Tulsi gabard you
have to understand one thing everyone's
very focused on the 2024 election I get
it I get it I get it if and when Trump
wins or even if Biden wins who knows
this is their last term they're done
whoever the VP is is
automatically the favorite to win the
presidency in
2028 whether it's Tulsi God that would
be whether it's Tulsi whether it's Cary
Lake whether it's s Huck coulde dogf
face Sanders whatever it is or why you
going to dig at her bro she's not what
what does her looks got to go with an
attractive female no you have to go with
what's my girl that I like Christy Noam
that's the girl that's the girl it won't
be Christy no it won't be that's the
girl I can tell you right now I'm just
letting you know that's the girl'll be
the favorite whoever the different
reasons Christine won't be the candidate
okay I want to hear that but whoever it
is guys you acknowledge Trump's VP if he
wins would automatically be the favorite
in 2020 and I think so he's gonna want
undying loyalty from whoever that VP is
if he doesn't have it well if you think
about Sarah H Sanders then it's funny
that you you brought her up uh and not
to change topics did you heard the story
about what happened with her and Trump I
have yeah yeah yeah you have to tell
that story tell the story all right so
for everybody out there this is
hilarious that you brought up I didn't I
wasn't even going to go there but
there's a su I'm going to do it fast a
summit in Singapore 2018 uh 2018 Trump
is talking to Kim Jong-un all right and
where he reluctantly accepted a Tic Tac
from Trump who dramatically blew it in
the air to reassure Kim that it was a
breath met and not a capsule of poison
think about it Trump had to go look I'm
not dead so they talked about Sports
women's soccer then Sanders say she
looked up to notice Kim Kim Jong-un
staring at her cuz she's hot uh and um
he appeared to wink at me and she
appeared stunned right Sarah hucke
Sanders Sarah Huckabee Sanders Kim
jung-un looked at her with his dope ass
haircut of went and winked at her so she
goes all I could think was what just
happened surely Kim Jong-un did not just
Mark me then later in the presidential
limousine the beast on the way to the
airport Sanders tells you know Trump
like Kim Jung and Trump was like he hit
on you he did he effing hit on you and
then she goes sir please stop I'm but
Christian and then you know what Trump
says to her well Sarah that settles it
you're going to North Korea and you're
taking one for the team your husband and
kids will miss you but you'll be a hero
to your
country
taking for the team s and by the way
there's witnesses that that cooperate
the story if you don't think that that's
the dopest that's that's why I love
Trump it's cuz there's like that
100% oh my God what a loser Kim Jong-un
is have any girl he wants
Sarah I'm going to double down on this
to the day I no you know what him the
nuke just hook up with him once it won't
hurt you like big fat pigs here we go oh
my God what a you know what I I I don't
like Memoirs that put those kind of
things out and I'll tell you why have
some fun cuz the media is going to take
it and run with it saying you're sexist
can Tom at this point you can ask Sarah
heab Sanders did you think it was kind
of funny did you think it was there she
said I thought it was funny but I
thought it was a little inappropriate
but you were privately in a limo with
you know with eight other people a
couple Secret Service guys at president
a few people so it wasn't like
one-on-one and you get all upset about
these things she's the one that P Tom
it's called locker room talk the only
reason story is okay the only way I'm
okay with that story cuz she put it in
her book no no no I'm only okay with
that story one way only one way huh if
she called Trump and Trump's gave the
okay I agree if she didn't make that
call to Trump I have a very big problem
with very good point I'm just telling
you because if if you if you did that
without my permission then we don't have
a relationship good we're done you can't
I can't have you around in a private
setting you can always have a what do
you call it a a professional away from
no no there's a in football what do they
call whenti arm you got AEP arm you can
be away and we can see at each other
high great but in back behind closed
doors with a door and you want to do
that no by the way if he called Trump if
she called Trump you think want TR what
do you think Trump would say go for for
I think so but but guess what if she
didn't Trump will never trust her again
that's my problem for example let's
let's just say you let's just say Adam's
writing a book okay you're writing a
book Tom's writing a book yep like look
Pat that one time when that happened are
you okay if I post I'm like let me think
about it yeah yeah and I say you know
what go ahead and do it great when
people come out and say man can't
believe Adam said this about you I said
he called me yeah he asked he called me
and I said yes and you got to respect
the guy that did that I'm okay with that
that's the truth that's what happened
you think she you think you you think
she did it I don't know I'm
not Vinnie look at it this way let's say
you're writing a book and it' be a popup
just letting you know can barely read I
read gooder than you you have to you
can't you have to get permission you
have to get permission from your boss
Pat is right let's say you're writing a
book and you are hypothetically Obama
chef and you're going to put some stuff
in a book Jes
okay so you're saying he didn't get a
permission he didn't get a permission if
you don't get permission it could have
white shark somehow showed up in a lake
W it could affect your swimming that's
pretty crazy okay so uh do like here's
the next prediction before we wrap the
segment up and go to the next uh next uh
uh story who do you think is dropping
out next and when R when
great as soon as he fails in New
Hampshire when is New Hampshire when is
New Hamshire when is New Hampshire Rob
is it two months a month I thought it
was February no I think it's com Come on
talk to me Tom it's in a couple weeks I
thought it was two
weeks when is New Hampshire no it's not
September 10th
no New Hampshire anyway so you're saying
right after New Hampshire yeah once he
finishes in third place in New Hampshire
I think he's finished you think look
let's get real here guys all we're doing
is perpetuating what's inevitably
Nikki's out Ron's out Trump's the winner
even VC said before he dropped out
January 23 it was two weeks okay exactly
month he said he predicted let's see if
if a knows what he's talking about in
this regard that he believes that the
santis is going to drop out and become
Nikki's VP I don't see it I don't
believe it but that's what he said do
you recall that I did I do I do and but
by the way that would be the kiss of
death bless you that would be the kiss
of death to desantis's presidential run
if he dropped out to be Haley's VP the
kiss of death both what do you mean I
think both of them are going nowhere and
if they join together there it's a road
to
nowhere but the difference is the santis
has a shot at doing something in the
future if he gets behind Trump Haley
does not no Haley does not no because
because the right knows and they realize
what she is and they expose her for
being the war hawk and being the girl
that that got rich if Haley is driven by
being a president here's one thing Haley
can do and it would throw everybody a
full-blown curveball you ready if she
agrees to be a VP to Nome or Michelle
Obama or something like that and stays
as a republican this has happened before
where two tickets uh this this was 80
years ago or something like that
Republican chose a Democrat as a VP or a
Democrat chose a republican as a VP some
something like that that that took place
that would be one way for her to flip if
if the Democratic party really wants to
have a shakeup guess what I think Haley
is for sale if Democratic party really
wants to have a shakeup if she got a
couple million dollars from a boing
contract are you kidding me what would a
$30 million Netflix documentary do a lot
so to me there is that uh part I think
again I've never spoken to this person I
don't know who Nikki Haley is I've never
had a conversation I would have loved to
have a conversation with her on the
podcast but she doesn't do podcast she
only do we invited I think at one point
even rob you they got back and they were
going to do it and last minute they
canceled something like that that's
exactly what happened last minute they
canceled she was snapping her fingers at
Rob and he said I can't do when you do
that you're telling the world you're I'm
too good for you guys to come talk to
you and we're going to take your word
for it if that's what it is but if she
wants to be part of the P Community man
there's plenty of pompous people on the
left that she can go join it would be a
perfect fit for her big time so the
question you had asked was when do you
think the S is going to go out look the
election is next week the premier
election New Hampshire is next week
Emerson had the most accurate polling in
um New Hampshire they were as they were
closer to what the actual of vote came
out as anybody else and they have the
most recent polling in New Hampshire
Trump 45 Haley 28 Christy 12 Dana 7
Ramis Swani 6 so either Des sis is
either out this
week or he does it Des STIs is out this
week pre New Hampshire yeah either he
goes out this week or he goes out next
to did you see his speech or no yeah
well his speech was borderline psychotic
what did just say he attacks the media
he said the media is defending Donald
Trump they are the veritable petorian
guard and most people don't even know
what that was it Roman guard Gladiator
and you know I and when I saw that thing
from Dan sanis I said to myself man
those are the last words of a desperate
candidate so next week he may
finish fourth next week um what do you
mean fourth there's only three
candidates in it no no no he's tied with
with VC dropped dropped out is V still
on the paper ballot is no he dropped out
that's what dropped out means I think
the F the funniest thing that happened
with Ronda Sanz though some guy walked
up to him while he was with his wife and
gave him a participation Trophy and it
was hilarious did you see that Adam the
guy that gave
the you can put in your I I don't know
what the uh what the rules are on New
Hampshire Tom we're on the same page
here the Sanz is done he's finished he's
cooked he's gone whether it happens this
week or next week after New Hampshire by
way did you see what s manager said play
the clip I just sent you Rob it's 26
seconds the sanz's campaign manager lost
it when he was being interviewed on I
want to say NBC or whoever this is what
channel is this yeah NBC oh wow he was
Furious to say why are you guys calling
it why are you guys calling it so early
why are you guys calling it why are you
guys calling it and and partly they're
right on why you're calling it but they
were calling it because the lead was so
yeah you know massive that it's like
listen guy what do you every yeah can
you play this
clip hope you enjoy I think I think it
was results from some sort of survey or
something not not even true votes well
no no no this was this was projected
Based on data and science data and
Science and not actual election results
and we'll have some of our experts
explain explain how that was decided and
why it was called in the way it was
later in the show
but because I don't like it if the left
does it the right I don't care if
anybody does it just just wait the
numbers going to go a little bit higher
you know you got a little bit more to go
and then you can say and the way you can
do it based on math cuz the last Iowa I
think was 180,000 people that casted a
vote this time it was a can you pull
some numbers said 116 some said 130 it
wasn't a big number no so you know why a
lot of people didn't even show up
they're like listen this for what Trump
has got such a big lead what am I voting
for there's no reason to show up and
even in our last presidential election
which was so contested the most of the
news media you know the big ones televis
and the online ones waited till the
polls close and they would say we're
waiting till the poll closes in Wyoming
however Trump has a very significant
lead over Biden they would say that but
we're waiting to call it and put the
number on the board until the polls
close they've usually have had that sort
of I'm going to use a word here
gentlemanly approach to the elections so
I think that guy has a point why don't
we wait till the polls close yeah well
look to use some football terms when the
KY chiefs were up 24-7 against the
Dolphins with 4 minutes remaining in the
game they're like all right guys we're
ready to call it and then there's people
be like hold on there's still four
minutes left the Dolph believe me the
Dolphins aren't making a comeback the
santis ain't making a comeback Trump
you're watching that video if you're
watching that video they had only done
Trump at 25,000 no I get that so to me
all I'm saying is wait another hour like
what do you you wait another hour so for
example for us like when we would do
recognition if you did it too early guys
would them about I'm like I don't
even want to hear you bitching Aon it so
guess what let's wait till the results
are done and here's what guess you're
lost okay cool B let's move on and then
that was a kind of that's the only thing
I'm saying that I support what the guy
is saying and uh you know Tom kind of
has an exp look at the smile on Tom what
are you laughing at Tom I'm laughing
what what what Adam just said yeah CU in
the NFL unlike Arizona elections Dolphin
players don't mysteriously and suddenly
appear in the end zone yeah it's like
seven more for the dolphins where' that
guy come from yeah weird yeah definitely
weird sometimes the Dolphins make what a
rough week to be a Dallas Cowboys fan
right like the worst loss in the history
cuz their quarterback's name is Dakota
and they suck Dakota by the way Prescott
name is Dakota yeah Stephen A Smith's
Ling he had a great week with Jason
Whitlock and now but it's but it's
pretty bad on what happened there so
let's go to the next store here faa's
diversity push includes focus on hiring
people Rob if you want to get that video
ready folks brace for impact
faa's diversity push in includes focus
on hiring people with ready severe
intellectual and psychiatric
disabilities what yeah do that's not a
joke did you guys understand what I just
let me look okay let me read this
article to you to to see what FAA is
doing and what direction these guys are
going the Federal Aviation
Administration has launched a diversity
and inclusion hiring initiative
targeting individuals with severe
intellectual ability disabilities look
look at it right there on the screen
okay and psychiatric disorders and
various physical and mental conditions
as specified on the agency's
website the fa's approach is grounded in
the belief that diversity is integral to
achieving fa's mission of ensuring safe
and efficient uh travel across our
nation and Beyond controversy has arisen
regarding the potential safety
implications of prioritizing diversity
equity and inclusion initiatives in
aviation industry figures like like Elon
musks have expressed concerns asking do
you want to fly in an airplane where
they prioritize Dei hiring over your
safety while actively promoting
diversity in FA maintains that
individuals with severe mental and
physical disabilities constitute an
un underrepresented segment in the
federal Workforce here's a CEO of United
uh U Airlines being interviewed and the
guy even pushes him which the
interviewers is probably even more
annoying than the CEO when you listen to
just go and watch it for yourself go
ahead Rob kby from United go ahead how
is diversity and diversity targets
working into the avate academy we have
committed that 50% of the class of of
the classes will be women or people of
color today only 19% of our Pilots at
United Airlines are women or people of
color and by the way from all the data
I've seen that's the highest of any
airline in the country white nails don't
just dominate in the cockpits also in
the sea suite at United Airlines well
look at United I'm proud of the
diversity that we actually have in our
our SE Suite I think if you look around
Corporate America correct me if I'm
saying though so I this was just based
off your website the people you list as
Executives but out of 11 people three
are women I believe one is a person of
color um that's correct um but you know
in Corporate America I think you know
that's a low bar how do you raise your
own bar well a lot of this is you know
focusing on it we have uh programs to
one of the things we do is for every job
when we do an interview require women
and people of color to be involved
bringing people in early in their
careers as
well right there any thoughts okay guys
was it was was some of this sarcasm what
is happening here Adam when it comes
this is as real as it this is not a was
the guying him he's grueling him for not
being the enough he's okay got it yeah
he's like you're only at 19% I Need You
Higher we're doing better than anyone
buddy this is the FAA I want everybody
to know just just last week a freaking
door flew off of an airplane because
some guy didn't do their jobs right so
listen to this and I'm going to break
down what you said and little boy lost
his shirt and a boy lost his shirt God
forbid I hope it wasn't his lucky one
all the passengers lost his listen
to the language okay they're hiring
severe not mild not regular but severe
intellectual disabilities which
translates to dumb psychiatric disorders
crazy and various physical and mental
conditions mental let's say for
what it is and by the way that who you
guys just saw was Scott Kirby Rob I sent
you a link of who he is he said 50% are
going to be women people of color an
lgbtq Community it's called United calls
it flying with pride show this Rob this
is him in Drag and I don't give a
like I don't care what he does who's
this this is the CEO keep going around
that's the CEO the CEO of of of United
goes and hit he's incorporating drag
into their business and sponsoring drag
shows that's no wonder why he wants
everybody cuz he wants to be inclusion
of all his friends and listen Adam
everybody out there with all due respect
if I'm about to board a flight and I
just happen to look into the cockpit and
I see two lesbian Pilots one is Indian
one is Middle Eastern one is wearing a
helmet and eating jello I'm running the
off that plane I'm s listen let me
explain something to you I'm going like
no and I'm leaving but because hear me
out de Dei I'm totally fine with it if
it's at Starbucks and it and and the
Barista is a non-binary vegan with green
hair that is wearing a mask with a bull
ring I don't give a it's coffee if
they mess up I'll be like okay who's the
normal give me the regular coffee this
is my life this is flying on an airplane
and I'm telling you guys right now how
long do you think until this thing
backfires and God forbid a United
Airline crashes because of this
right here when are we gonna stop
playing the game of guys we got to make
everybody happy I will never ever get on
another United Airline flight ever and
if you're a United Airline frequent
flyer mile whatever I would look into
either getting your money having them
cash that in because it's horseshit what
by the way that that's FAA that means
every they're hiring everybody at the
airport everybody that works for the
airlines are going to be crazy M like
can you imagine the flight attendants
now going hey everybody put on your seat
belt even though I don't know how to use
it like what are we talking about what
are we can I add one thing why how
correct Vinnie is and I'm speaking from
personal experience this is why Dei must
diie okay play around with some letters
you brought up the uh the air the
airplane analogy right if you look into
the cockpit now the reason I say that I
have personal experience with this my
father all he did he ran a business in
the 80s and '90s he hired only
handicapped individuals did you hear me
tell them what is that
I'm following I'm following you he had a
marketing company this is pre- internet
they they handed out flyers in the
neighborhood okay my father was born
with Cerebral paly it only affected him
physically mentally very sharp very
smart guy to ingratiate himself with the
community he hired specifically
handicapped people to give them jobs all
they had to do was walk around the block
yeah and deliver Flyers put it in
mailbox there was a good chance they
missed the mailbox okay I'm just letting
you know honest I would every night at
dinner I would
have mentally handicapped individuals we
called them a different word back then
retards at dinner I was raised among
these people okay it was the most insane
obnoxious hilarious dinners of my life
hence why I became a comedian but my
father pillar of the community gave
these guys jobs because they had know
there opportunities to have jobs what's
my point there's a difference between
handing up flyers and flying a
plane okay we a great Point that's my
point there's a difference so when you
look in the cockpit and the guy turns
around he's like hello it's
like I'm cool with you greeting people
down there but you hit the nail on the
head Bingo thank you severe intellectual
disabilities she what are we talking
this is like stop playing but it's not a
joke they're going by Way by way it's
already in what Adam saying is so true
because you know everybody has a friend
that somebody in their family has severe
intellectual or psychiatric disabilities
there's nobody that's listening to this
that doesn't have somebody there this
this doesn't mean our level of sympathy
needs to get to the point of
compromising the safety of families
traveling whatever the job they may have
that's not uh uh you go to uh I go to
this movie theater every time I go to
the movie theater the guy that checks my
ticket he's in a wheelchair and you know
what I think about you know honestly
what I think about good for AMC for
hiring this guy know I'm like you know
what the first thought I'm like good for
AMC good for you he's always there and
all he does is go this to the what do
you call it the QR code and me Tio and
Dylan and the kids we go and watch the
movie awesome that versus this slightly
different now somebody say what if their
job isn't that big of a job in the
liability and the responsibilities in
there fair that is a fair argument
you're making I think the part that is
delusional and confusing is the
following what percentage of a 100 girls
under the age of 12 versus a 100 boys
you just do a basic uh uh market
research how many of you want to grow up
to be a
pilot what percentage of girls under the
age of 12 will say I want to be a pilot
versus what percentage of girls under
the age of TW boys will say they want to
be a pilot if 30% of boys say they want
want to be a pilot and 5% of girls say
they want to be a pilot and it's 6X the
reason why companies have men as Pilots
is not because they're racist it's
because more boys want to be a pilot one
day and girls don't what percentage of
nurses same thing with kids with nurses
what percent you can go on with these
questions you can't force a career upon
a kid that doesn't want the damn job
just because you're trying to bow down
to the ESG community and kiss their
asses that's the problem The Logical
reasonable American people have and I
understand Vinnie's frustration I
understand the humor with the Perfect
Analogy he just gave with his father but
this is this this lacks common sense so
we can joke about this all we want it's
no longer funny FAA and it's no longer
funny United Airlines people are sitting
there saying I just want you to get me
from LA to New York get me from Dallas
to Miami that's all I want honest I
don't care what that person is in there
what nationality they are what
background they are if they're male or
female just prove the results and then
we can sit there and say okay this makes
sense by the way I'm going to go to the
next Story the next story is the hurt
story okay so I asked a question
yesterday why is Herz dropping all these
Teslas okay and Tom gave the most
logical reasonable answer I'm like okay
that makes sense to me on why they would
do that Herz is selling no I'm sorry Tom
didn't give that Rob gave that yes when
we were um good job Rob podcast prep
Herz is selling 20,000 EVS so it can buy
more gas guzzlers The Verge look at the
title of it the title is doing what it's
trashing Hurtz meaning no matter what
hurts does they're not winning yes
they're selling 20,000 EV so it can buy
more gas guzzlers but is hurts making
the right decision if you read the full
story and logic behind it it sounds like
they are so 20,000 cars approximately 13
of its Global EV Fleet is what they're
selling and use the proceeds to purchase
gas powerered vehicles after facing
unexpected depreciation and damage cost
amounting to $245 million for its EVS
the decision aims to better balance
Supply against expected demand of EVS as
the company couldn't find enough
customers for its EVS despite previously
setting a 25% EV Fleet Target for 2024
again I love this one they say by 2035
there will be no gas guzzling cars in
the state of California and then Common
Sense hits results hits and you realize
it's not an effective method Nome but
it's a good campaign message for you to
give herts shift from scaling up to EV
ambition to selling off its eveve
reflects the challenges faced by the
company and the broader industry as
softening demand and EV ownership
challenges such as charging and upkeep
impact plans for Ev adoption while EV
sales continue to grow the rate of
growth has slowed prompting companies to
reassess their EV investment rob you
have a uh uh Tesla yourself right and
you're a Tesla owner so what what what
logic do you see with the store here
yourself well first of all whenever
there's from my experience anytime
there's an issue with your Tesla the
only person that can fix it if there's
any type of mechanical issue is a Tesla
representative or Elon Musk yes um like
when I needed to get my tires rotated I
didn't take it to a shop they came to me
they sent a Tesla technician to my house
and switched out the the tires from the
front to the back um and then the other
thing is charging with these vehicles
it's if you're not if you don't have
hands-on experience with the vehicles
it's very hard to understand how the
charging Works um when you go faster you
eat more of the battery away so you have
to pre-plan some of that stuff you'll
get in the car and you'll put in your
destination it'll tell you how much
battery you have how many miles to get
there but if you go 75 or above it
dwindles and it so a lot of people will
run out of power not knowing that
they're not going to get to a charger in
time and it's not like there's charging
stations every couple of blocks you're
talking about 40 50 60 mil in between
charging stations so if you run low on
battery the only way that you can get to
a charging station if the battery runs
out is they send a tow truck out to get
you they put your car on the tow truck
and then they drive that to the charging
station nothing runs on gas let me ask
Rob a question because I'm not trying to
put your business out there but you've
had some issues with your Teslas let's
just say that I yeah I total okay okay
and Malik's crashed you've been some
accidents you hadu but yet you continue
to return back to Tesla and you bought
another Tesla safest vehicle I've ever
owned that's why so what's the reason
it's a I would have died if I was in any
other type of car uh in the Collision
that I was in I spun out somebody rear
ended me I spun out on the highway hit a
guard rail going 75 mil hour totaled the
car walked away completely unharmed no
not concussion nothing no unarmed what
did I say unarmed unarmed but you are
armed uh I was unharmed in the accident
so that's why I went back for there're
great vehicles uh econ ically it doesn't
cost me anything to charge this thing up
and it's a very safe vehicle for me and
my kids gotta safety this with Herz what
do you have with this by the way great
commentary Rob Tom what are your
thoughts love well I I line up Herz had
the number one problem they had was the
customers weren't taking it so they
couldn't find enough customers to rent
the EV so it started there but then it
went to all the things that you talked
about Rob talked about which is you know
if you don't drive an EV a lot you don't
know how to charge it and you don't know
how to set it and a lot of times these
EVS were getting run out of gas and
getting stalled someplace because people
that didn't understand it were running
them out of gas so there was a cost so
there was a bunch of cost underlying
Hertz in this and the fact that the uh
audience the people that were renting
from here didn't want it and The Verge
likes to say buy more gas guzzlers no
they're not they're buying a bunch of
cars that are four-cylinder engines some
of them are even hybrids and that's what
they're buying for the fleet so it's not
like they're buying a bunch of you know
BMW m5s to get 11 miles a gallon here
that's that's what's going on so The
Verge you know congratulations for
spinning the headline but oh I'm sorry I
just noticed it's The Verge um and so
what Herz has done is the Practical
thing they said hey we got to go back to
fuel efficient cars that everybody wants
to rent so they don't get stranded and
then the other thing is is what he was
pointing out is EVs do not have an
infrastructure for repair so her is
making the right decision I have the
same thing I have a Fisker that's in my
tiny little Fleet of bis do cars and you
know I you know there's things that only
Fisker can work on if it ever comes to
that and I and I know that and that's a
a risk I take something I accept you
know by supporting that company with
their car right now and supporting EVS
up to a point because I think a blend is
good but Herz everybody's jumping on
Herz here but Herz is just doing the the
normal thing I can't get enough people
to rent these things and I got increased
cost of the ones that I have and so I'm
gonna so I'm going to sell them and
that's that and by the way Herz is also
suffering because Herz has been impacted
by Uber and turo is actually mentioned
in a quarterly earnings report um I
believe it was Enterprise They mentioned
turo which you can rent a car from
somebody else a day turo is basically
the um Airbnb for cars turo is like the
churos they sell at Magic Mountain
cousin of that Mexican DT but the point
is Herz and AIS and all the car r
companies have been hit by Uber and true
Tom you want a herds
donut all right let's go let's go to the
next Reflections we're going to find out
what's going to happen so Rob pull up uh
W Davos is meeting here and what they
said is the crisis they're most worried
about two years versus 10 years okay so
these are the things they put out just
recently what things to be worried about
two years versus 10 years in the
two-year side World economic Forum uh
you will see at number 10 pollution then
economic downturn then
involuntary migration
involuntary migration then inflation
lack of Economic Opportunity Interstate
armed conflict Rob can you zoom in a
little bit cyber security number four
and then you have uh uh social uh
polarization societal polarization
extreme weather events and number one is
what misinformation and disinformation
of course because of election yeah look
at the 10 year number go to 10 years
number 10 is pollution then it's look
how many of them are green by the way
everything's about climate change right
to know look how many them are green so
pollution societal polarization cyber
security and voluntary migration adverse
outcomes of AI technology misinformation
disinformation so we're going to stop
lying lying is going to decrease in the
next 10 years from mainstream media is
what they're saying so natural resource
shortage and then what is that one blood
diversity biodiversity four is code for
overpopulation using up the Earth wow
natural resource shortage and
biodiversity loss and ecosystem collapse
critical change to Earth Systems and
number one extreme weather events Tom
you see this what do you think about I I
think over 10 years they're worried
about population and number five and six
is maybe they're worried about their
control of messaging and then
involuntary migration I don't think they
really care and then societal
polarization I don't think they really
care they're using that as a tool right
now to everybody against each other but
then number 10 pollution is directly
related to number three so three of
these on here actually four of them are
related to we as the people there's too
many of us and we're crushing the Earth
that we've been given and we don't have
the ability to control the messaging
properly and then this migration thing's
going to be a problem too and by the way
involuntary migration you know why
that's a problem Pat because you have
too many poor people over here that are
trying to get over there so it's also
overpopulated
the one of their core tenants and I've
said this like 10 times last 5 minutes
is they want to solve overpopulation and
the way they solve it is not good yeah
oh you you know how else you could help
in depopulating people have diversity
for Pilots for United but by the way
look at two years number one oh you want
to kill people have Pilots be that
that's 200 people a pop look at two
years right now number one Global threat
to them is misinformation and
disinformation but notice how they're
going to bust their asses cuz it's Elon
Musk at the end of the today I don't I
don't think people realize and I've said
this before how much credit you have to
take your hat off to Elon Musk because
he's giving us the you know why he's
such a threat guys why Elam mus is such
a threat to the establishment because we
get to see and hear everything that's
negative about the government and big
Pharma fizer and madna and all these
idiots anyway um number one is
misinformation disinformation Tom in
their 10e plan they're going to get rid
of people like him they're going to try
to discredit him they're going to try to
get rid of his business and that's why
on 10 years he drops down people like
that drop down the five so right now
it's control the information push all
that uh climate change and
climate stuff which is going to take
over the next 10 years that's what I see
when I see that chart well I actually
agree with why number one this year
would be misinformation and
disinformation because of all the
elections that are taking place in 2024
we just saw Taiwan so whether it's
misinformation or disinformation or CIS
information and you identify is a
straight white information guy the the
information we're going to see deep
fakes we're going to see AI generated
stuff we're going to see all that
especially in the election cycle here in
the United States especially with Russia
tampering elections especially with Iran
and you know all their friends out there
uh causing Terror we're going to see
misinformation and disinformation in
2024 no doubt but their long-term agenda
is certainly the U climate crisis and
overpopulation I like how 56 and seven
are not a problem in 10 years yeah weird
armed conflict lack of economic
inflation no no we're going to fix all
that with a one world government and we
don't fight each other anymore let's go
to the last story before we wrap up
Taiwan defies China electing a new
president Beijing labeled a separatist
Troublemaker this is from the NBC news
so China taiwan's vice president liing
was elected as a new president despite
warnings from Beijing not to support him
labeled by China as a separa
Troublemaker the election is seen as an
as a significant development in the
already strained relationships between
China and United States but with Taiwan
status uh being a sensitive issue lays
Victory extends the rule of the
democratic Progressive Party DPP and
marks the first time in taiwan's history
as a democracy that the same political
party has won three consecutive terms
however the DPP lost control of the
legislative which may constraint lay
policy options China's resp sponsor La
Victory remains uncertain but potential
actions could include military
drills trade uh restrictions on
Taiwanese companies and cyber attacks
and even Bloomberg a story comes out
same day from uh uh about Biden saying
Biden says us doesn't support taiwan's
Independence after vote Joe Biden said
we do not support Independence
clarifying that the US position on
taiwan's Independence following the
re-election of taiwan's democratic
Progressive Party which aims to limit
China's influence China considers Taiwan
as territory and hope that taiwan's vice
president Le chinte who maintained
strong ties with the US would not be
elected President Biden remarks however
have escalate escalated tensions in us
China relations regarding potential
military inversion pbd you did a poll of
whether you thought China would invade
Taiwan in
2024 what were the results of that poll
do you recall let me let me pull it up
because I want to say was 7030 if I if I
remember they thought they were they
weren't I think 70 was this was a couple
days ago right I'm just interested in
what happened in that poll I'll give it
to you right now go ahead and give you a
commentary I'll look forward but where
you're looking at it up is here we go
the there it is right there okay so it
was pretty close yes but what we know is
let's just start with the facts in 2024
there's more elections going what 40% of
the globe is having elections is that
the number so the world is voting okay
and you vote with your feet and you vote
with your pocket B and you vote with you
know hopefully against War right now
there's three hot spots going on around
the world we know Ukraine we know about
Israel but we don't know exactly what's
going on in China and Taiwan we know
about the South China seas and
everything going on over there but what
happened in Taiwan and this is important
because they basically said China no
thank you we're aligning ourselves with
the United States and not they're not
the only country that was formerly part
of China or that part of the world that
is essentially aligning with the United
States and I'll show you with that so
they are not aligned with the CCP that's
what's going on in China I'm I'm sorry
in Taiwan and China is not exactly happy
about this so much so the Philippine
prime minister and the Philippines came
out and they basically congratulated the
the new Taiwanese PR um president China
the CCP said be careful Philippines
quote unquote you're playing with fire
but here's what's going around in the
rest of the world they pulled 20
countries major
countries do you view the us or China
more favorably pretty interesting 20
countries 18 of which said they viewed
us more favorably than China the
countries Japan South Korea Israel
Poland India Italy Hungary South Africa
France Indonesia Greece Canada Brazil
Argentina Spain Netherlands Mexico
Australia and obviously the US the only
countries that align themselves with
China Nigeria and Kenya wonder why
because they probably gave them billions
of dollars and bought them off now
that's what confessions of an econom
Hitman will'll find out what happens
with Nigeria and Kenya but even more
importantly they asked who do you say
contributes to more peace and stability
in the world the US and China and they
asked major countries India they
answered 70% us
33% China wow okay Japan 79% us 14%
China in South Korea 74% us 133% China
it's becoming clear and clear you need
to pick a team are you on team autocrat
or are you on team democracy are you on
team China Russia Iran houthis Hezbollah
Hamas are you on team democracy and the
Free World with the United States pick
your team these are these are goes back
to the first clip at the very beginning
of our podcast today yep America First
based on what John Stewart said right so
we're at the end of the podcast uh gang
tomorrow
uh I will be interviewing John Abramson
we'll be talking about big Pharma very
very interesting topics here we got
cover a lot of stuff today I think
Thursday do we have home team Thursday
or do we have a guest on Thursday
Thursday is home team Friday glenbeck
Friday glenbeck Thursday home team okay
in the house so and by the way today uh
uh with everything that we covered with
manck for those of you guys that wanted
to vote Rob if you can bring this up
please Vinnie it looks like you want to
say something to everybody have to say
something first of all I think I got
like 22 in here I love every single one
of you that are on there please man me I
want to give a shout out to the first
five like I promised John coester TJ
Turner Jeff rosinski Toby schwarzbauer I
said it right Jordan black and Robert
love guys thank you God bless you listen
I love them but I'm trying to beat them
man me please I love you guys ask me
anything take care everybody we'll do
this again tomorrow bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye I got